you're in a coma you know this is a
dream
memories everyone in a coma now goes to
the same color space here in coma some
people develop unique abilities in order
to discover those abilities a person
needs a little push
so we put in danger I'm wondering what
your special ability is gonna be
the men from the balcony
you see the leader he taught us how to
survive we're here for a reason
everyone who's here didn't make it in
reality they didn't have a future there
you haven't figured out anything yet
I'm the commander here
this world is made of memories
how did they get here there's an island
for your papers somewhere in the coma
we're always looking for people who can
help us get there
is this my life now I remember that I
couldn't be together with who I wanted
to be here it's possible
our world would never appreciate
something unusual even if it's a hundred
times better
what do you need reality for after that
we need to wake up you can't wake up do
you understand your body is there in
coma you are here there's nothing you
can do about it
life in coma is as real as it gets I
said holding
[Music]
you
you